the beach soleil serait plage
tu as passé un bon week end je me suis
fait chier
mode nuit votre famille
30 à londres à
plein temps ont changé et tony
qui aimerait retrouver ta fille c'est ça
a été a besoin de moi elle donne des
cours de danse à paris
salut je suis ton père je suis parti à
20 ans elle sait même pas qui tu es
inscris-toi son cours de danse peut-être
annoncé
l'ambassade pense pas être la tête
la danse c'est sa passion si tu lui
montres que tu aimes ça peut savoir
c'est un point commun côtés
et vous vous appelez devine que rim sur
nous comme les chanteurs
vous madame
lara fabian ok
non ce mic des bottes kevin est la fille
de kombouaré c'est quoi ça des
claquettes chaussettes
je veux tu sors mon partenaire au
prochain championnat du monde il faut
que tu lui dises qui tu es
c'est ridicule je sais pas danser tu vas
apprendre tout s'apprend
[Musique]
pendant ce parce qu'on en a besoin juste
toi
et moi
c'est moi qui ai fait ça est un peu moi
aussi
[Musique]